[Musica]
credo di dovermi adeguare al tema
generale che è stato proposto sul buon
vento che cosa che fa nella costituzione
col vento il vento è una metafora ma è
anche una realtà fisica che ha
caratterizzato la vita del mediterraneo
ci si occupa del vento che deve spingere
le vele quando il vento non c'è bonaccia
ci si ferma il vento non è come la neve
che si può produrre artificialmente
quanto non erika abbastanza per shari
quando il vento non c'è bisogna avere i
motori nel nostro caso il vento che
serve per farci andare avanti e quello
che già una volta più volte nella storia
l'umanità percepito quando non c'era piu
niente da sperare quando non c'era più
vento
pensate agli ebrei nel deserto ci hai
portato qui a morire mentre il almeno
avevamo le cipolle d'egitto
pensiamo alla situazione contemporanea
ma che cosa dobbiamo sperare nel futuro
per ragioni economiche psicologiche
emozionali per ragioni tecniche non si
riesce ad avere un futuro bisogna
migrare andare da un'altra parte
ecco la costituzione italiana è stata
percepita da giuseppe dossetti un
professore di diritto uno dei padri
costituenti come una compagna di viaggio
frate v della costituzione una compagna
di viaggio non vi deluderà vi potrà
aiutare
qualunque sia la meta che vi proponiamo
un vecchio detto antico suggerisce che
non c'è buon vento per i marinai che non
hanno un porto ma dove vuoi andare
basta questo vento
ecco nella negli atti degli apostoli
troviamo l'esperienza di quel vento che
spira dove vuole e che induce le persone
a intendersi ciascuna nel proprio
dialetto l'arabo il parto in giro dice
manzoni in su orser mong rudy è stato
capace di farci intendere ma aveva anche
detto il giovinotto di nazareth
a me va anche detto non su questo monte
o su quest'altro monte si potrà adorare
dio ma in spirito e verità
ora la parola evento assomiglierà parola
spirito con lo spirito è la vita e la
vita serve per parlare per respirare per
muoversi la vita serve per evitare che
ci fermiamo che ci addormentiamo socrate
rappresentava se stesso come un tafano
che punge quella mucca che atene che
tende ad addormentarsi e lui lavoro e
svegliare la bella e la vigilia che
consiste nell'attendere anche quando il
buio c'è e non sappiamo come si faccia a
superarlo sentinella quanto manca
dell'alba ecco abbiamo bisogno di
trovare delle albe e io che sono più
grande dei ragazzi che oggi si preparano
all'esame di maturità portando anche
cittadinanza e costituzione come teva
avranno circa 10 minuti per derogare di
questa roba non sono nelle loro
condizioni
uno di loro ha detto ma doveva
prepararsi con un tema libertà e
democrazia ha detto ma io veramente
sulla libertà non so molto bene cosa sia
con la si possa confrontare con la
dittatura perchè io la detta turano
sperimentata e quindi non mi sento di
parlare con competenza su questi due
temi
io mi sono sentito mancare evidentemente
il frutto della l'insegnamento della
storia e della costituzione nell'alto la
nostra scuola non deve essere
efficacissima se produce questo
e siccome io sono nato nel 1935 cero
allora fattivo la scuola elementare
quando il duce aveva sempre ragione e
quando ci garantiva tutti ci dava la
sicurezza
c'era scritto sui muri noi avevamo anche
negli slogan molti nemici molto onore la
carta geografica ci faceva intendere che
di qua ci sono i buoni dai cattivi e noi
dovevamo prepararci fin da piccoli e io
chi ero
era un balilla per gli maniero è stato
un figlio della lupa
ma insomma avevo una m
ma non in fucilino che veniva dal suo
ruolo ipad il balilla avanguardisti e
poi ai giovani fascisti che con il
fucino andavano a fare le manifestazioni
e l'idea era che è meglio vivere un
giorno da leone piuttosto che certo a
100 anni da pecora quindi la guerra la
vittoria la conquista erano concentrate
in una frase che era riportata dietro la
tessera della gilli che voleva dire
gioventù italiana del littorio editori
erano dei soldati romani che portavano i
fasci che rappresentavano l'umidità del
popolo romano bene
c'era scritto in nome di dio e della
patria io giuro di obbedire sempre agli
ordini del duce e di dare se necessario
il mio sangue per la patria italiana
ecco mi viene in mente che oggi se uno
vuole dare il sangue si rivolge alla bis
per dare la vita a qualcuno che sta male
non per fare la guerra che produce i
disastri che ha prodotto
allora la domanda fondamentale è questa
ma dopo che non c'era più il duce che ci
dava la garanzia sicurezza che aveva
sempre ragione quando non ha avuto più
ragione a che cosa ci si è affidati
ecco questo è il punto la debolezza
della scelta alternativa a quella del
duce
purtroppo quella ci è andata male allora
cosa bisogna fare abbiamo a cercarne un
altro
ecco della storia succede questo che si
è determinato in certi casi il caos si è
usciti dal caos perché un capo ha
guidato un popolo e ha fatto sì che
quello si sentisse unito si sentisse
forte sintesi di verso tutti gli altri
magari il centro del mondo in ogni paese
c'è uno che pensa che l'ombelico del
mondo siano loro che la lingua
fondamentale sia la loro per i greci gli
altri che parlavano lingue diverse erano
i barbaro e una volta che si scopre che
questo popolo vittorioso con un capo
vittorioso alla fine
ieri sera abbiamo visto una bellissima
luna ha ricordato diversi del pascoli il
quale in alexandros grande condottiero
che ha fatto più cose di tutto il mondo
dice ormai non c'è più niente da
conquistare la storia infinita direbbe
fukuyama c'è solo quello che vi brilla
nel brughiere nel vostro scudo cioè la
luna per dire la luna non si immaginava
che ci si potesse andare ma il futuro
sta soltanto sei sempre nel conquistare
qualche cosa nel porsi deve qualcosa
deve avere qualcosa di più oppure il
futuro sta anche nel ricordare guardate
che nel linguaggio biblico
la cosa fondamentale è il ricordo scema
israel ricorda che è successo che
eravamo sconfitti ma chi siamo risaliti
ci ha aiutato il signore il profeta se
aiutato il re david eccetera eccetera
abbiamo trovato dentro di noi la forza
di qualcuno magari anche i più giovani
ecco vedete non solo nella costituzione
italiana c'è scritto che la repubblica
riconosce e garantisce i diritti
dell'uomo come singolo e nelle
formazioni sociali ove si svolge la sua
personalità
e richiede l'adempimento dei doveri
indispensabili di solidarietà politiche
economiche e sociali
ecco queste sono le condizioni che
consentono di non sentirsi balilla di
non sentirsi vittorioso di non dover
andare a conquistare l'africa per
diventare imperatore il re imperatore
era il savoia quando io ero piccolino
ecco c'è la possibilità di vivere
riconosciuti dallo stato
avendo una repubblica un regno è un re
nicolò da piccolo poi se con diventato
cittadino ma non si sa bene che cosa
voglia dire cittadino si deve italia ed
europa per che cosa sono i diritti e
doveri e quali quali sono fondamentali
oppure sono aperti e ciascuno può fare
quello che vuole
ecco il terzo articolo della
costituzione riconosce che noi siamo
tutti uguali in libertà dell'uguaglianza
ma riconosce che siamo tutti uguali in
dignità sostanzialmente e questo vuol
dire che se ci sono mancanza di libertà
e disuguaglianze la repubblica deve
intervenire e rimuovere gli ostacoli che
limitando di fatto la libertà e
l'uguaglianza dei cittadini impediscono
il pieno sviluppo della persona umana
ecco il punto quindi è qualcosa da fare
qualcosa per il quale qualcuno ha
giurato che era possibile hanno
accettato di cominciare di fare un nuovo
stato cambiando la struttura
fondamentale lo statuto c'era i miei
tempi poi la coesione ci si mette la
struttura dello stato
le gerarchie i poteri divisi non tutto
nelle mani di uno parlamento governo
magistratura scuola i valori quali sono
i valori dove stanno questi valori se
noi ascoltiamo la radio la televisione
diciamo tutti i diritti affermati e
tutti i valori proclamati sono
cancellati dalla seconda parte del
telegiornale se guardiamo raidue usa la
prima se guardiamo un altro tipo di rai
allora è vero che non possiamo godere di
fatto di tutti ma al tempo della
costituzione la nostra e quella tedesca
per esempio dice la dignità umana è
inviolabile ed è compito di ogni organo
dello stato quello di rispettarla e
farla rispettare
la dichiarazione universale dei diritti
dell'uomo che è avvenuta nel 1948 un
anno dopo la nostra costituzione che è
stata approvata nel 47 dicono che dice
questa dichiarazione che è fatta questa
dichiarazione che riconosce la dignità
di ciascuno dell'unica famiglia umana
eccetera
questa dichiarazione è fatta al fine che
ogni individuo e ogni organo della
società avendo costantemente presente
questa dichiarazione si sforzi con
l'insegnamento e l'educazione di rendere
questi diritti a queste libertà
effettivamente conosciuti e rispettati
in qualunque parte del mondo
allora dice ogni individuo anche i
bambini
ecco i discepoli e maestri quello che i
maestri magari cattivi maestri non sanno
fare perché non sono stati capaci di
portarsi dietro qualcosa che
assomigliasse alla costituzione alla
violazione dei diritti umani possono
farlo i piccoli se noi guardiamo
una ragazza come ma l'ala yousafzai che
è diventata premio nobel per la pace era
stata ferita a morte sparati in faccia
perché andava a scuola
lei ha difeso i diritti umani la dignità
umana della donna che deve studiare ecco
e attraverso una matita e una penna non
attraverso una pistola semi di essere
una pistola con davanti il talebano che
mi ha sparato io non gli sparerei e fa
riferimento a buddha a gesù cristo a
martin luther king e al suo profeta
pakistano eccetera
questo ho imparato da queste persone e
questo messaggio l'aiuta a sostenere la
sua diciamo pure emotività
tanto che lei va dal ban ki moon
allora segretario generale delle nazioni
unite gli porta 4 milioni di firme
raccolte e dice non ho paura
io ho trovato tutta la forza necessaria
per affrontare questo mondo e adesso
continua la sua azione quelli come altri
prima un ragazzino di 13 anni è morto
sparato da qualcuno ha difeso i suoi
compagni che erano trattati da schiavi e
molto a 13 anni ha rifiutato una borsa
di studio per l'inghilterra perché
perché preferiva continuare la lotta è
come lui lo spirito ha funzionato anche
seri in pakistan lontano da noi non
conosciuto non ho apprezzato abbastanza
come rené cassin che dice anche se le
nazioni unite sparissero anche se
sparissero tutte le conquiste che sono
state fatte non verrebbe meno questa
rappresentazione che l'umanità fa di se
e questa testimonianza che da di se e
vero che non era maggioranza che noi
vediamo
libera democratica al lavoro con
serenità eccetera
e vero questo ma è anche vero che se ci
facciamo una compagna di strada come la
costituzione maestri e discepoli
potranno andare insieme e garantire la
continuità di questa idea è di questa
possibilità di generazione in
generazione
grazie